is lying cheating stealing and being an
sob a successful strategy in life there
are of course greedy and selfish people
but we don't have to endorse Gordon
Gekkos view that greed is good any more
than we believe that selfishness is a
virtue this Christian morality of
sacrifice and altruism is wrong the
marvel of the market is that through the
invisible hand the efforts of the greedy
and selfish are channeled to serve the
interests of others why not live the
best happiest most flourishing most
successful most engaging life that I can
possibly live compassion is a virtue
self-actualization is a virtue but
selfishness is not a virtue and advance
is no
welcome to the sella 4 we're a monthly
debate series that features topics of
special interest to libertarians and
aims to enhance social and professional
ties within New York City's libertarian
community this is an Oxford style of
debate in which the audience initially
votes for against or undecided on the
resolution whoever moves the vote in his
or her favor is declared the winner go
into solo vote.com to cast your initial
vote you'll find that tonight's
resolution reads selfishness is a virtue
we're partnered with Reason magazine and
presenting these debates and you can
catch audio of all our events on the
recent podcast which you'll find in the
iTunes Store thanks to the Smith Family
Foundation for making this series
possible for more information and to buy
tickets to our future debates go to our
website at the solo forum dot org I'm
Jean Epstein director of the solo forum
arguing for the affirmative on the
resolution selfishness is a virtue we
have Yaron Brook director of the iron
Rand Institute
Yaron please come to the stage
and since I will be arguing for the
negative
I must recuse myself as a moderator for
our guest moderator we are honored to
bring you Judge Andrew Napolitano judge
please come to the stage I feel like
this is some kind of a conspiracy of the
basement of an old theater
everybody's Italian Catholic Jewish or
atheist very happy to be here so Iran
has the burden of proving the case that
selfishness is a virtue and will start
his time now oh and wait once you're on
starts the voting is closed until we are
told that it's open again which it will
open at the end of the debate nice all
right good evening everybody
I can't see you I think you're there
Thank You Jean for inviting me and for
choosing this particular topic for us to
debate I'm really looking forward to
this and thank you judge for moderating
tonight's events and thank you all for
being here tonight
selfishness is a virtue now that is a
difficult proposition to make in the
world in which we live in a world in
which selfishness is perceived to be a
real vice right what are we associated
with the would selfishness we associate
in popular culture with lying stealing
cheating backstabbing being a real sob
exploiting other people for one's own
benefit that is what the culture has
come to identify with the term selfish
self-interest egoist all of those terms
when we point that somebody in
schoolyard and say that kids selfish
what we mean by that is he's a nasty
nasty person he's going to do any
think to anybody to get his way there's
a problem because at the same time as
that is true it's also true if you think
a little objectively about the world
selfish which means taking care of self
and we see artists pursuing their
passion and willing to give up
everything to achieve their goal that
they set for themselves well that's
pretty selfish we see business leaders
trying to make money by trading by
producing by making think Steve Jobs
what a selfish guy how many people in
the audience were asked by Steve Jobs
what features you wanted in the iPhone I
can't see you but I'm guessing the
answer zero Steve Jobs built iPhone the
way he wanted it to be
he built that iPhone in his image to
pursue a passion of his for the monetary
benefit of himself Steve Jobs was
selfish and he athletes out there
Michael Phelps who work tirelessly to
become the greatest swimmer in history
for whom for me he cares that I enjoy
watching swimming no for his parents I
hope not he did it for himself he was
being selfish so what's happened is that
we have this term that has these mixed
meanings inside of it it has this idea
of exploitation a being mean a be nasty
of being bad and at the same time and as
all these positive things associated
pursuing your values pursuing your
passion trading making building we call
this a package deal when you take one
concept and you put two things inside of
them two things that ultimately attain
that contradictory because when you
actually look at life and when you have
time to look at history and look at the
people around you and look at who is
successful and who fails
his lying cheating stealing and being an
sob a successful strategy in life does
it actually lead other than in politics
does it actually lead to success and
prosperity and happiness and and living
a full human life flourishing as a human
being and then that says no if you
actually look at the world around us
Bernie Madoff lanced up in jail but more
than that
Bernie Madoff is miserable before he's
caught not because he feels some innate
guilt because he's lied and cheated and
steal but because he has no self-esteem
because he lied steeped in the chills
because he can't look his kids in the
eye because he can't have a conversation
because something might slip out and
they will discover that he lied stole
and cheated of course it was the kids
who told the feds about him
you know god forbid this is he actually
catches anybody who commits fraud the
too busy monitoring Don and my 13 DS and
13 G's right so no it doesn't pay off
it's not in your self-interest to be the
SOB in the schoolyard those people don't
turn out well they live all over
miserable pathetic lives and this is by
the way truer politicians I've never met
a happy politician all you have to do is
look at Bill Clinton or Hillary Clinton
and see how miserable they are they
carry it on their faces and I think this
is and I think this is true of most
politicians I met a lot of politicians
I've never met a happy politician they
all look miserable because they've
achieved what they've achieved primarily
through lying cheating some of them
through stealing but if you ever
wondered how these guys go into office
poor and come out rich I mean it's just
weird
$250,000 speaking fees at Goldman Sachs
so we've got a muddled concept what a
selfishness actually mean if you look it
up in the dictionary it says taking care
of self , any modern dictionary has the
comma at the expense of others
now what the held at the expense of
others where did that come from the only
people with an incentive to add that at
the expense of others of the people who
wants you not to be selfish who wants
you to sacrifice who wants you to think
always in terms of the public good and
the public interest in the common and
who are those all the people who want to
control you
the people who want to tell you how to
live and what to do because they know
what's good for the public they don't
want you to live for yourself because
they know that people who live for
themselves want to be free you want to
be free of Authority free of coercion
free of force so the only people who
want you to live for the public interest
for the common good are the people who
will get a channel that public good in
the common interest to you and tell you
how to live and destroy your ability to
be free but more than that we be taught
for 2,000 years that what is good is the
sacrifice what is good is to live for
others what is good is not your
happiness but other people's happiness
and and altruism is an ism it means
other ISM and Augustine compt who came
up with the term altruism didn't mean be
nice to people and opening doors even
ego is open doors for people I know
that's a shock for you guys no August
ecomp meant that altruism means living
for the sake of others living for the
sake of the happiness living for the
sake of they war being and the standard
of your morality is how much you've
sacrificed for the sake of other people
in other words how much you have
suffered for the sake of other people
Bill Gates makes seventy billion dollars
by changing the world and making people
better off I'm not gonna explain the
traitors trade of principle to this
audience I think you understand it that
the only way to become super rich is to
benefit other people through trade but
he gets zero more credit for that
negative Mall credit card he did I made
make seventy billion dollars in the
Phocis but he leaves Microsoft and
starts a charity oh now he's a good guy
not quite a saint now I don't have any
inroads with the Catholic Church I'll
have to ask the judge about this but I
suspect
I suspect it to become a saint
Bill Gates will have to do what yeah I'd
have to give it all the way move in live
in a tent and maybe show us a little bit
of blood because that's what
conventional morality suggests it
suggests that virtue equals suffering
have you ever seen a painting in a
museum of a saint with a smile on their
face no that's not the point the whole
point is to suffer it's not how much you
benefit other people if it was based on
how much you benefit other people Bill
Gates would already be a saint it's how
much you suffer and the question has to
be asked why why is other people's
happiness more important than mine why
should I live for some common good I
don't know any be common why should I
live for the public interest I don't
know the public
why shouldn't I live I've got one shot
at this this is the atheist in me coming
out right I've got one shot of this I've
got one world in which to live why not
make the most of my life in this world
why not live the best happiest most
flourishing most successful most
engaging life that I can possibly live
and what is such a life require now this
I think is what morality should really
be studying morality should be the
science that studies what virtues and
values people should pursue in order to
achieve their maximum potential in order
to live the best life that they can live
now that would be an amazing project a
project started by Aristotle continued
by Iran that is a project worth engaging
in what are those actions that we take
the really lead scientifically to a good
life because we're a biological entity
we have a particular nature some things
hurt us something's a good first just
like some food is poison other food is
good for us so certain actions that we
take in our life certain virtues that we
engage in a good fuss and others are bad
for us we have a particular nature so
let's try to focus on what is good for
us and do that and it turns out and
again you don't need to be a nuclear
scientist to figure this out it turns
out that what's good for us is not
exploiting other people it's not lying
cheating and stealing it's using that
one thing that one resource that we have
that makes us human all our values come
from one place all our values come from
one activity all of our values spiritual
as well as material and that is a human
mind
a reasoning capability to be selfish
means to be rational it means to use
reason it means to think about your own
life and how you can maximize your own
well-being you own capacity to flourish
over a lifetime long term rationally
that's what virtue of selfishness really
means it needs to think to engage with
the world with your mind to figure out
the actions necessary and the values
worth pursuing that will lead to a good
flourishing successful life at the end
of the day your happiness is the purpose
what other reason are we here for if not
to live to flourish to be happy and not
not not the happiness that comes from a
line of cocaine the happiness that comes
and living a good life from producing
from creating from building something
from making your life have meaning
having a purpose having self-esteem so
selfishness is the only virtue in a
sense it's the purpose of life his life
is your life make the most of it make
the most of it by thinking by reasoning
and by living thank you
thank you you're on Jean Epstein will
now make the negative case for 12
minutes well my friend Yaron Brook is a
force of nature in the cause of freedom
and free markets and I put iron Rand in
the pantheon and not just because of her
and the enduring impact of her novels in
our Objectivist writings Rand reminds us
that there is a real world out there and
that the only way to understand it is
through reason but is selfishness a
virtue
Yaron says yes and so did Rand she
applied reason to this question in your
book of 1964 the virtue of selfishness
so let's go back to the seminal text
we'll find that on the rational terms
Rand herself set selfishness is clearly
not a virtue Rand begins by confronting
the question of why she chose the word
selfishness to quote denote virtuous
qualities of character in characteristic
fashion she answers quote for the reason
that makes people afraid of it she
continues the meaning ascribed in
popular usage to the word selfishness is
not merely wrong it is responsible for
the moral for the arrested moral
development of mankind yet she continues
the exact meaning and dictionary
definition of the word selfishness is
concerned with one's own interests this
concept does not include a moral
evaluation now
yayin has at times referred to
selfishness as ran to find it but in her
own statement ran maimed it made it
clear that it would be unreasonable for
her to define an english word according
to her own preferences that's why she
cites the quote exact meaning and
dictionary definition of the word which
does not include a moral evaluation now
Yaron just commend
did cite the exact meaning and death and
definition of the word because it always
includes a moral evaluation it always
means ever since Samuel Johnson's
dictionary was written in 1773 and on
through all of Webster's dictionaries it
always means moral disapproval the
dictionary writers were doing their job
by reflecting the fact that all written
rip records of the word have used it in
this way the only difference between
what Yaron just said and what iron rend
wrote is that she was quoting what she
called the exact dictionary different
definition of the word and she could
defined it as concern with one's own
interests . not concerned with Owens own
interest to the detriment of others not
to the expense of others . just
concerned with one's own interests so
grant was being rational she was pinning
a definition on the dictionary but she
was miss quoting the dictionary now why
the sleight-of-hand
why did Rand pretend she was citing the
dictionary when she was clearly not
doing so think of the Eroica struggles
she went through as an immigrant from
the Soviet Union imagine that like Rand
you and I grew up with the suffocating
idea that anyone who refuses to serve
the state is selfish also imagine that
even in the u.s. we witness President
John F Kennedy in his 1961 inaugural
address declare to much acclaim that we
citizens must all ask what we can do for
our country if we have these experiences
we too might want to shout from the
rooftops that selfishness is a virtue
just to jolt people out of their
civility to the state we too might want
to rail against what Rand called the
arrested moral development of mankind by
calling selfishness the virtue given the
popularity of Kennedy's statement but
since we don't bear rands scars we don't
have to go down that false and
destructive route
and neither does Yaron to echo the words
ran herself used in her book her use of
the word selfishness is not merely wrong
it's done serious damage to public
perception of the set of beliefs that
yerin and I both share the use of the
term needlessly antagonizes people by
making it seem as though we who advocate
freedom really do endorse a world in
which people act in disregard of or at
the expense of others it does harm in
another way I've met followers of Rand
who know what the word selfish really
means and like to flaunt their
indifference to others these people do
us no service in a speech Rand delivered
she attacked Kennedy's statement which
read in full ask not what your country
can do for you ask what you can do for
your country and in 1962 two years
before the virtue of selfishness was
published a free-market economist Milton
Friedman took a principled stand against
that statement in his book capitalism
and freedom the same principle stand
Rand had taken but he declared that the
free man will asked neither what his
country can do for him nor what he can
do for his country he will ask rather
how can we keep the government from
destroying the very freedom we establish
it to protect joining Friedman and
picking up on a phrase she herself
strongly endorsed ran might have
declared that the individuals pursuit of
happiness as a virtue we're picking up
on a popular word in the 1960s she might
have argued that quote
self-actualization is a virtue
especially since self actualization has
been defined as the achievement of one's
full potential through creativity
independence spontaneity and a grasp of
the real world there are of course
greedy and selfish people but we don't
have to endorse Gordon Gekkos view that
greed is good any more than we believe
that selfishness is a virtue instead
instead we cite Adam Smith's concept of
the invisible hand
as Smith pointed out in a market economy
greedy and selfish people can satisfy
their aims only by selling us products
we want to buy the selfish are therefore
led by a hand that is invisible them to
them to advance the interests of others
Yaron has written that business is a
selfish activity and is a simple matter
to correct yahrens abuse of the english
language through smith's classic insight
about the invisible hand for smith who
deployed selfishness business can't be a
selfish activity precisely because it
advances the interests of others and as
he explains the marvel of the market is
that through the invisible hand the
efforts of the greedy and selfish are
channeled to serve the interests of
others the distinction is simple people
may have selfish motives for offering
others products may they may want to buy
but the activity is not selfish in
itself and plenty of people are in
business for idealistic motives think of
Steve Jobs who by the way spoke about
money only as a means of investment in
the products he wanted to sell or of
John Mackey or Howard Roark of Rands
fountain novel The Fountainhead who
consciously devoted themselves to
offering products that enhance the world
now oddly enough yahrens tough
mindedness yields to naivete when he
says well honesty is the best policy for
all of us unfortunately even in a market
economy the moral does not work that way
Yaron may decide that dishonest people
and and and selfish people in this world
are personally unhappy but I wonder
economist Thomas Piketty and Paul
Krugman have been made millionaires by
the market for services that are without
merit and have in fact done great harm
you can bet that if these two con men or
countless others like them ever do pay
the piper it won't be until the
afterlife
what do Harvey fires Weinstein Jack
Warner Harry Cohn
Alfred Hitchcock and Louie be mayor have
in common
well there were all Hollywood producers
who were sexual predators against women
know what they don't have in common is
that only one of them
Harvey Weinstein ever got caught so we
must tough-minded Lee admit that honesty
is not always the best policy and that
the market that that people are often
naive and they buy snake oil from others
so we cannot endorse the idea that that
selfishness leads always to honesty
selfishness can sometimes pay off and to
those who think government is the answer
to regulating the potentially
destructive effects of breed and
selfishness we cite the public choice
theory of Nobel Prize winner James
Buchanan who called his theory politics
without romance greedy and selfish
opportunist will also be found in
government where the absence of market
constraints permits them to act
destructively and further their own
selfishness
however unhappy Bill Clinton and Hillary
Clinton are according to yerin who
probably hasn't had them confide in him
for quite a long time as young as Aaron
and I both know we advocates of less a
fair capitalism are the only ones who
can truly say that we care about the
well-being of the broad masses of people
while the Bernie Sanders of this world
are offering them snake oil that can
only make matters worse
ya'know has also disavowed selfishness
correctly defined in a recent interview
our owners was asked about whether he
believed in a social safety net and
here's what he said I believe in a
safety net I just don't believe the
government should provided I don't
believe I should be coerced out of them
you want to help them I went it weren't
to help them we can get together and
help them voluntarily notice that yerin
said I want to help them and so would I
Adam Smith could have had us in mind
when he wrote in 1759 how selfish so
ever
man maybe supposed there are evidently
some principles in this nature which
interests him in the fortune of others
are this kind is pity or compassion the
emotion which we feel for the misery of
others compassion is a virtue
self-actualization is a virtue but
selfishness is not a virtue you must
vote no on the resolution and in doing
so you'll be even truer to the rational
ideals that I earn Rand advocated thanks
[Applause]
Thank You Jean you're on you now have
five minutes of rebuttal and we trust
you will pull no punches and it's this
is gonna take a while so jeans view as
articulated is the view the most free
market supported since Adam Smith is
held how's that worked out for you guys
not very well we are losing the battle
for liberty
we're losing the battle for freedom
exactly because of this view out of
Smith laid the foundation for the defeat
of the system he tried to defend by
positing that the activities of people
in the marketplace was selfish and
therefore yeah not so very positive mala
Lee but if you aggregate them and you
bring in something called the invisible
hand somehow they become virtuous he
laid the death knell for capitalism
nobody believes that if you add up vices
you get a virtue it doesn't make any
sense
indeed morally it is offensive and that
is why even though almost all mala lists
agree with that of Smith that the
individual's behavior is selfish
therefore bad they conclude then when
you aggregate them all up you must get a
bad one plus one equals two by inventing
an invisible hand that is not explained
Molly I'm not talking about economically
economically we understand how it works
annasmith lay the foundation for the
defeat of capitalism and unfortunately
one of the great tragedies of the 20th
century is that free market economists
continue with that deceit no the action
of the Baker in trying to take care of
himself and his family is the essence of
virtue what is more important than
living your life and making the best of
your life and taking care of the people
you love that is the essential
characteristic or what virtue is about
now Jean of course has to as all
opponents of selfishness have to create
strong men in order to attack a man's
view yes Steve Jobs didn't care about
the money but nobody said selfishness
was about money
selfishness is about human flourishing
much that's not money as a component but
money is not everything
so of course Steve Jobs didn't care
about the additional dollar though he
cared in terms of measuring his success
and how in the success of his product
but yeah Steve Jobs did what he did why
because he loved it he did it for
himself hopefully you all go to work and
love what you do for whom for you
it's your self-esteem it's your job it's
your life and that is all selfish and we
can play dictionary games here but the
fact is that the people who wrote the
dictionaries don't want us to believe in
selfishness the people who write the
dictionaries want us to believe it's a
vice because they want us to hold a self
sacrificial altruistic morality because
they want altruism is the great
mechanism by which to control us all but
which stain flick guilt in us all so
think about why we regulate business we
regulate business because we have this
confusion about selfishness they're
obviously selfish Steve Jobs was
obviously selfish but selfish people are
people who like steal and cheat and
they're so bees generally says Steve
Jobs must also be in spite of his
turtleneck shirts and being cool also be
a lying stealing sob
so we better get that government on his
on his on his shoulder to watch and
monitor we we reach to be 12th because
you businessman a too selfish to
consider the fate of other people I
think selfish people have a huge
interest in the fate of other people
it's not their top priority charities
not a top priority but charity is part
of life particularly in a free market
where there is no where they're not
taking 55 percent of our of our money
there's no contradiction between some
charity and selfishness so you have to
create a straw man in order to to knock
it down Steve Jobs businessman generally
of course they're greedy
they're trying to make more money what's
wrong with that there's nothing wrong
with that but if we have a negative
perception of greed and selfishness
we're obviously going to want to
regulate and control so the battle in my
view for free markets the battle in my
view for liberty and freedom is not an
economic about our you won that 50 60 70
years ago maybe you even wonder with
Adam Smith the battle is to eradicate
the old Christian judo christian ever
you want to call it morality of altruism
morality of living for the sake of
others and replace it with a morality of
the virtue of selfishness thank you
[Applause]
let him have it Jane Karl Popper Karl
Popper the philosopher once said no
rational argument will have a rational
effect on a man who does not want to
adopt a rational attitude and it it's
very clear that on the one hand Iran did
have a rational attitude she did not
permit herself to define a word like
selfishness according to her own
preferences she cited the dictionary
albeit erroneously now yerin is
unfortunately enthralled to the cult of
Iran's personality if she lays down the
law that selfishness is a virtue we've
got to stick to it no matter what
doesn't matter
if everybody else knows what the word
really means we've got to stick to it
well a yaran has talked about how we've
been arguing for free markets for a long
time and where did that get us well he
probably knows that 30 40 years ago
libertarians would have their meetings
in phone booths because they're usually
only 2 or 3 of them in any city now we
are countless now there are numerous
libertarians he probably knows that free
markets since 1776 have played a huge
role despite what government has tried
to do to lift the living standards of
the broad masses of people and I trust
he recognizes that it's really just a
desire to be in people's faces to try to
use a word that offends most people and
to use the kind of word that's meant as
an insult and have put down with others
because of course Yaron doesn't think
that act that Adam Smith was truly
retrograde in his views I just quoted
his book Theory of Moral Sentiments in
which Adam Schiff said that that that
most people do have how selfish so ever
they are there is compassion in all of
us so that's Adam
Smith talking his concept of the
invisible and is an extremely valuable
one precisely because we must
tough-minded Li recognize that there are
selfish people in this world totally
self-interested self loving types but if
they want greedy people and if they want
to survive then they have to provide us
with products we want to buy
it's the selfish and the greedy prey on
us precisely avaya by the way the Bill
Clinton's and the Hillary's and the rest
of them via government so all of that is
straightforward I Rand could have echoed
Milton Friedman he was writing two years
before and putting down Kennedy's views
he was coming out for freedom of self
actualization Iran could have stood up
for any number of things I cut her a lot
of slack she was a refugee from the
Soviet Union she experienced the horrors
of Bolshevism she wanted to be in our
face about these matters I deeply
respect her but there's no reason for
yerin who carries her torch to continue
to alienate so many progressives so many
people who think that libertarians are
uncaring with this silly word
selfishness why doesn't look what would
I have a quote from from Mike from that
movie with agree with Michael Douglas
playing Gordon Gekko greed is good
he writes greed is good you know greed
greed for knowledge agreed for for
bettering yourself greed brings
evolution it's all very nice and
persuasive and I no doubt if Aaron if
I'm Rand had written greed is a virtue
and then she said all greed really means
is wanting a little bit more
it doesn't mean of course wanting more
to access a deck it's not an ugly
fashion yeah and unfortunately might
again be in thrall to our cult and go
around calling greed a virtue it's that
this silliness should stop Yaron is
indeed a force listen to some of his
interviews when he talks about crony
capitalism when he talks about about
about charity
the safety net all of those things are
extremely valuable he is an asset to our
movement and so are the vast majority of
people who subscribe to objectivism and
to Iran's view I'm only asking them to
quit the madness quit talking about
talking in terms of these silly words
that everybody knows are offensive and
quit trying to claim that they're good
you don't need that vocabulary to defend
free markets and freedom thank you all
right gee and I'll let you Kent your
catch your breath for just a minute
because I want to put a question to you
first
well the other questions come in and Jim
has begun to text me the questions that
are coming in from the folks that are
not with us aren't you and you're on
really on the same page and isn't this
just a semantic argument over the sounds
of the words selfish and doesn't it
really have nothing to do with Iran
nothing to do with Iran well it's greed
can I ask you a question judges no no no
no this is this is my courtroom and I've
put the question to you professor Iran
I'm Rand wrote a book called
the virtue of selfishness she put it out
into the language she defended the
virtue of selfishness she said I want
this word to be out there precisely
because it gets people upset this is the
exact meaning of the word ever since she
wrote that book in 1964 a good many
decades ago we've been hearing this
selfish mantra over and over again from
Yaran so it's not and others so it's
hardly hardly something that has nothing
to do with Iran she put it out there and
she put it out there because she was a
refugee from Bolshevism and she hated
hated the state that would accuse her of
being selfish because she didn't serve
the state we don't bear her scars we
don't have to continue this this foolish
satire you're on respond please
well I think it's ridiculous to tribute
everything you don't like about Iran to
experiences in the Soviet
Union but you know the this there's this
tendency now to make everybody a product
of their environment
a man was a genius she knew exactly what
she was doing when she suggested the
word selfish she was trying to overturn
a mall tradition she was trying to
question and challenge the long-standing
primarily Christian but secular as well
tradition of self-sacrifice and altruism
and she was arguing that if you believe
in man not forget economics forget
freedom forget politics if you believe
in you as a human being then what we
need is a different morality a different
mall code she was challenging Adam Smith
his moral code
she believed and I believe and I know he
thinks I'm just a mouthpiece for an
unthinking I guess multiplying man
that's what was the suggestion
no one could suggest that you were
unthinking well I think G did it I
called you a force of nature in the
course of freedom and free markets but
no and I believe it bit to me to me
freedom of free markets are secondary to
me much more important is what
individuals pursue in the own life the
kind of life you as an individual take
on yourself and most important to me is
the kind of life I take on for myself
and what Iran is trying to do is
challenge us is safe this Christian
morality of sacrifice and altruism is
wrong the morality that Adam Smith
upheld in the Theory of Moral Sentiments
is wrong it's anti life it's anti human
and ultimately to anti freedom and anti
capitalism and she is presenting in that
essay a new morality and to the extent
that we as a fleamarket movement don't
take that seriously we will ultimately
lose this is a battle the battle for
liberty and freedom that is won or lost
in philosophy and morality not in
economics and if we don't pick up the
mantle you don't like the word selfish
use self-interest use egoist but the
idea of placing one's own life one's own
will
one's own flushing at the at the at the
center of one's life as the goal of
one's life that is crucial to our
victory political and economic my more
importantly again it's crucial to you
living a good life and that's what you
should care about you should care about
living a good life all right I know you
want to catch your breath but the
questions of starting over match my
dress so here's here's a very
interesting question for Iran if a
selfish person does immoral actions such
as donating to a charity because it
makes him feel better can we really call
it selfishness look wouldn't it just be
the empathy of the inherent human
condition but you see the the question
has already bought into the anti
morality that I believe giving to
charity is not necessarily Maul it might
be it might not be what makes it Maul is
is it rationally in your self-interest
to give to charity and I believe in some
situations it is and it's on situations
it isn't if it comes out of the money
that you would feed your kids it is
downright evil to give to charity if it
if your kids are more important your
neighbors kids you know how many of you
if your kids are drowning and your
neighbor kids are drowning go for the
neighbor's kid's first you selfish
bastard you love your children more than
your neighbors children ok but no so so
the framework has to be that the
framework of this new moral code is not
is that what is your self-interest is
more so charity is more only if it's in
your self-interest if you if it's
irrationally supportive of your life in
some way and I believe charity can be
alright but is it always bearing in mind
that professor Epstein's offspring is
seated in the front row it wants to
address the choice of who to rescue I'm
kidding you want to respond to this
look look again I think jeans yet again
I I we could throw out a lot of
different words for on rent and for yarn
to defend the word self-interest by the
way is essentially in the dictionary
it's it's it's a it's a milder version
he's a self-interested person slightly
larger than selfish look we have a lot
self-actualization the pursuit of
happiness all of the individuals pursuit
of happiness is a virtue isn't that good
enough for all of us
for the other Yaron self-actualization
is a virtue individuals do matter and
that's partly because partly because I
believe that yerin and I both share Adam
Smith's view that we are all
compassionate some of us very
compassionate Adam Smith even added that
you find compassion even in the worst
brigand oh that's simple vocabulary that
the English language offers covers all
the bases that yerin is so concerned
about so we don't need to misuse and
abuse and do violence to the English
language by establishing these
principles with respect to his comment
about charity of course there are a lot
of charitable people in this audience
and your concern it's a lot of hard work
as I've spoken to some of these people I
could mention Don Smith who's in the
front row whose finances it's a lot of
hard work to make sure that your money
is going to a good cause hopefully Don
Smith still thinks that the soul forum
is a good cause and yeah and I bet a
mind on man keep laddering him yeah well
I don't exactly so we don't know but of
course yarn is right in so far as that's
concerned but why did why does he have
to throw verbal wreckage at statements
that he's made points I mean let me just
quickly address this you look selfish is
opposed to what it supposed to selfless
we have lived in a selfless
selfish so the and that's the choice
because again for 2000 years we've been
told that goodness lies in being
selfless
I'm not selfless I think being selfless
is bad is wrong and to counter that is
the word selfish and yeah we can be
defined we can rewrite the dictionaries
that's that's a good thing to do that's
a good thing to do in some cases and let
me just boast one other bubble the gene
has I don't think compassion is that
important not only compassion changes
the world the confessions nice most of
us are compassionate sometimes there's
some people I'm not compassionate at all
towards at all but compassionate is not
a major virtue at all in my view all
right I have one more question
hang on ginger from from the streamers
which is a good one because of the your
very eloquent reliance on words
why do you rely so heavily on the
dictionary definition which is tainted
by 2,000 years of historical adoration
of self-sacrifice you're you're on Iran
did not text me that question as far as
you know it came from your son's
filtering out here we granting
potentially granting that assumption
about the dictionary about the English
language about how Adams with Jane
Austen and others use words we are
unfortunately Yaron and I and everybody
in the audience we are stuck we have to
deal with it with the cards that are
played us there are many many words that
by the way change their meaning over
time that have ambiguous definitions but
this word is not one of them it's always
meant moral and to meant to convey moral
disapproval so we are stuck with the
English language why should the devil
have the best tunes we've got to use the
devil's language but also addressing
yerin's concerned by the way I agree
with him and and and by the way in that
answer he gave about helping people in
need he made a very good point as well
which is echoing by the way Adam Smith
who said I have never known in the
wealth of nations when he's talking
about the invisible hand he says I have
never known much good done by those who
affected to trade for the public good
it's absolutely true that the market via
of the invisible hand we're greedy and
selfish people are involved and we're
the idealists are involved the market
takes care of human needs overwhelmingly
and indeed I probably rather and I share
the view that it seems to have been
antitrust who forced Bill Gates out of
his business Bill Gates did far more for
the world with his operating system that
pushed up the production possibility
frontier of the world then he has done
so far with his charity absolutely true
however as Yaron himself said there are
people in need who through no fault of
their own there are people who soup to
slip through the net and he and I both
believe in a social safety net done by
compassionate people all right Karen and
me now what now I'm going to address you
as the founder of this feast what is the
procedure now for getting the audience
to ask the question a lineup there's a
microphone there they're people they're
going to turn the lights up so I can see
them is there a questioner there please
please do your question great question
all right so well there while they're
lining up do you find problems dealing
with university students who are
repelled perhaps because of what their
professors have told them by the use of
the word selfish and cannot sell that
concept to their colleagues I don't
think I don't think the would is ever
the problem can you help young people
sell the concept of selfishness without
the sting often associated perhaps by
culture with that word absolutely
because if you translate it into caring
for self if you translate it into
flourishing as a human being making your
flourishing your prime e mol goal in
life that the goal in life is
of happiness what's more selfish than
the pursuit of happiness that is the
essence of selfishness is the pursuit of
happiness the essence of selfishness no
the the essence of selfishness as the
word means as and and as the word
definitely do note is that it means
somebody who pursues his own goals to
the detriment of others who rolls over
the interests of others is not
interested in this pursuit of happiness
this is the issue right because Jean
everytime returns to this mall
obligation that he feels towards charity
and towards helping the poor yes there
poor people but they're a minor issue in
a free market I just said that you the
issue of poor people is a minor trivial
issue and yet every conversation we keep
coming back to but we need a safety net
who you know saved in it yes making it
they'll be a safety net who cares it's
less than 1% of the people it's it's
that is not the barrier to explaining
capitalism can a people taking seriously
their own lives can a selfish person
contribute voluntarily to a safety net
and still remain selfish well I think
Harvey Weinstein probably contributed to
a safety net and and he's a real selfish
pick but I completely agree with to be
listening to me obvious behind I said
indeed I agree with him that a
flourishing capitalism where everybody
participates will take care of most
people the vast majority of us well it
will let the less standard of living of
the bread broad mass of people that has
to be taught to people absolutely and
yerin is an important voice for that of
course indeed
compassion is a relatively a minor
affair in that on the other hand we do
want idealist likes like Steve Jobs
people and how it worked by the way who
want to change the world through their
products real visionaries who care about
changing the world that's what most of
the great entrepreneurs were all about
they cared less about money than about
changing and helping the world in a
compassionate way before I go to the
podium to take questions from the
audience I can't see you are are there
questions all right good
the first one you reserve the right to
to edit them to rephrase them or
redirect them so no speech is just the
question sir your on jeans started off
twice by referencing an ran statement
that selfish is a neutral term so I
guess you lose but the whole book is
entitled the virtue of selfishness so
isn't there a equivocation between the
word selfish and selfishness the action
you're on are we hair splitting over the
meaning of words or is there an inherent
conflict between the concept of
selfishness and the concept of
virtuousness no there's no there's
obviously no conflict I think the two
are the same I think we're not splitting
woods because at the end of the day gene
and I disagree about the content of
morality in spite of here trying to deny
that fact to put aside the wood let's
forget selfishness the actual concept of
morality we disagree and he's trying to
paint my view as again he returns to
this idea of money nobody mentioned
money a man doesn't mention money in
that essay money is not what she's
talking about when she talks about the
virtue of selfishness with the virtue of
substance is about living it's on making
the most of your life that's what
selfishness is that's what selfishness
means and while in the big hood I don't
know what dictionary she pulled that
definition of I will leave I will
research that for genes sake I will send
him the reference in the dictionary
where she took that farm okay bet you
there was such a dictionary she didn't
make it up gene would you have this
conflict with your on if the word
selfishness did not have the odious
sting that it does suppose it was the
word flowers well that's the word I
guess I I guess if the word greed didn't
have the odious sting he's a greedy bat
greedy usually it's pretty bastard the
opposite of the word greedy I guess is
kid everybody gives the word greed the
word hateful the word Jew hater the word
all of those things if those words
didn't have a sting I guess I'd be all
for yerin that would be fine however
there are words that we use for people
who are morally odious
and that's part of our language that
important parts of the language now I
don't know if Harvey Weinstein was in it
for the money it seemed like he
basically why did the sex of course
that's true so I didn't say that selfish
predators like Weinstein are only after
money of course they may be after others
odious things of course but but these
hypothetical questions obviously have no
point bad people
good call Weinstein selfish you then are
confusing people by putting him in the
same back at Steve Jobs because
everybody knows Steve Jobs was selfish
because he was out there to pursue his
vision for the world not your vision for
the world his vision for change so so
what I'm asking for is to separate
Weinstein out and keep the purity of
Steve Jobs and you do that by not
calling Weinstein selfish but by calling
him what he truly is which is a predator
a self-destructive human being his
behavior see selfish means promoting
self Weinstein to not promote himself
Weinstein destroyed himself and just
look at him he's a destroyed human being
and he is a self just like Bernie Madoff
these people are self-destructive and to
call them selfish
confuses people about the nature of
capitalism and this is why one of the
reasons why we cannot convince people
because they think we know that business
men are selfish you're not gonna
convince us otherwise right and
selfishness is bad next question from
the audience Steve Jobs had a vision to
change the world and offer us who's next
from the audience yes Jay this question
is for your on so I'd like to probe a
little bit how you feel about a
situation where your self flourishing
and your self-actualization has to pit
against some kind of social duty or
responsibility towards say your family
members so you know a classic example is
a person who is called to be so
passionately involved in some kind of
calling that they may abandon their
parental responsibilities
or other kinds of social
responsibilities and you know is that
selfish and how do you feel about that
okay so can selfishness justify the
impairment of other voluntarily accepted
duties and responsibilities like being a
good parent so I don't consider being a
good parent of social responsibility I
don't know what social responsibility
means I don't know what that concept is
when you have a baby you are taking on a
responsibility you're taking on a
implicit contract to take care of this
child until they're an adult and that is
a primary responsibility it's not the
only responsibility you have but a
primary responsibility that you have to
for your own well-being for your selfish
own life no I know but you look
sometimes I sign a contract right and
halfway through the implementation that
contract I change my mind tough right I
still have the contract right and the
same thing with having kids you can
change your mind certainly many of us
somewhere around between nine months and
three years had a change of heart
over and over and over again but you
made that commitment when you have that
baby and it's in your selfish interest
to fulfill that commitment because you
couldn't live with yourself I think as a
complete human being otherwise many
people abandon that commitment and I
personally think I mean gee might not
agree with me I think Weinstein and all
those scumbags in Hollywood suffer the
consequence of the innate evil behavior
I think people abandon their children
suffer the consequences not in an
afterlife right here and now this life
you know they are dealt with
psychologically they're dealt with you
two let's let thank you thank you hold
on let's have another a question and
this one for Jean Epstein please so
who's up next with a question for Jean
Epstein sir do you think there's a
difference between sacrifice and
investment like a baseball player does a
sacrifice pop fly for his team I
sacrificed a mic but it was my kids that
went to college does anybody really do
something for something less or as you
said is it just
is it a bad investment or I think use
the word unreasonable but well okay now
I do think that there is a word called
compassion which Adams Ruth used and
that we all feel it and so people who
make sacrifices are to some degree
sacrifice of money sacrifice of time
they they feel compassion and they feel
good about it they are not selfish and
just a comment
it's the oddity and Aaron's view is
indeed that all selfish and hateful and
predatory people eventually have to pay
the piper
or that they're deeply unhappy this is
that honesty is always the best policy
this is unfortunately a terribly naive
view and so again I add that other
Hollywood producers Jack Warner Harry
Cohn Alfred Hitchcock Louie B mayor they
all got away with it and it's only
lately that people are not getting away
with it and it's a little silly it's a
little childish for us to say oh well
they were deeply unhappy in their heart
or that Paul Krugman or Thomas Piketty
actually will eventually look at
themselves in the mirror and realize
what professional liars they are and
even though they've been enriched by the
market again unfortunately rather naive
in that case as I say the crucial point
to bear in mind is that at least these
people are functioning in the market
they are selling snake oil and the
market is buying it Iran but how much
more dangerous would they be if they
were in government Iran do you want to
reply yeah I mean I'd say yeah I am
completely convinced that Paul Krugman
is suffering from the fact that he is a
real scumbag there's no question about
that but but again I don't equate money
with happiness yes he's making a lot of
money that doesn't mean much to me the
fact that he is cheating on reality the
fact that he is lying to himself and to
the world has has because I understand
human nature has consequences to his
consciousness he is not a flourishing
successful human being but let me answer
the question about sacrifice sacrifice
is another one of these terms that is
that is confused and many people use
sacrifice instead of investment I I
think that is a is bad English and bad
linguistics sacrifice is what Jesus did
he got crucified for sins he did not
commit he got crucified for your sins
sacrifice is giving up something more
important your life for the sake of
something less important your sins other
people's sins so sacrifice is a negative
it is a bad thing it's self sacrifice
but again a lot of people use it like in
basketball he sacrificed for the team
now he wants to win he's selfish he
wants his team to win and he's willing
to score few less points so take a few
less shots in order to achieve victory
that's what selfishness means so there
are a lot of terms unfortunately the bad
guys have made this very clear you see
in economics as well there were a lot of
terms that have be muddled by the people
who do not want us to realize our own
potential as human beings and there's a
lot of cleaning up the dictionary if you
will and sacrifice and selfishness are
two words that need to be cleaned up
yarn and I are both Jews who chose not
to follow Jesus so I agree with him
about that part of it by the way did you
have to bring Jesus into this
and what's this Jewish stuff what are
you talking about
Tonio you told me a pants kept kosher
you told me the guys kept kosher they're
Jews oh good okay gene do you wanna
reply to this and then we're gonna go to
the summations no it's okay no okay next
question for gene please actually my
question is to you both I want to bring
up an unlikely thinker I think a lefty
who by accident made the good points
about this topic Richard Dawkins
to be more precise in his book The
Selfish Gene he explains that
selfishness is about maximizing the
probability survival probability of your
genes and also your memes so that means
of course your thoughts whether it is
liberty or equality whatever so I think
he explains well in that regard because
that explains why I would care most
about mine okay can you put this in the
form of a question please sure could you
please comment you wanna check that one
first
mister energyne I mean there's a lot to
say about about the the book The Selfish
Gene and I think a lot of issues there
are a lot of a lot of challenges and
primarily human beings a difference
evolution has done something to human
beings that is amazing and great and we
have free will and we get to we get a
recode we're not just in spite of the
evolutionary psychologists we don't just
do what our genes tell us to do will
actually have reason and we have the
capacity to dictate what our life will
be so well Richard Dawkins perspective
on The Selfish Gene says all you want to
do is multiply and if that were the case
all we'd want to do is you know what it
is is everything everything we would do
would be focused on sex and and and and
and you know procreation I think we're
more than that because of the capacity
to reason because of the capacity to
rewrite the software if you will because
we have free will
all rather than just saying god I cannot
accommodate
you know you could you know there's a
movie I love called the hateful eight
now there's a maybe could have called
the book the greedy gene now obviously
when people write books they use titles
they might use our words and slightly
odd contexts but obviously when we are
talking in objective terms in rational
terms about the world then and about
human behavior then then then we have to
use words according to definitions that
in the case of selfish has never ever
changed there are words that do change
their meaning there are words that have
ambiguous meanings not words like greedy
hateful selfish all right in order to
keep to our pre-arranged time schedule
we're going to have the closing
arguments now you're on will go first
for five minutes and gene will follow
for five minutes and then we'll have the
voting so as Jean admitted woods change
over time for two thousand years those
who advocated for self sacrifice for for
enslaving the individual to the group
enslaving the individual to the
collective have wanted this to believe
that there are two alternatives in
morality two alternatives in living one
is to live for the sake of others to be
altruistic to place the well-being
happiness and good of other people above
self the alternative to that is be
presented as being a lying stealing
cheating sob selfish in other words
those are the two alternatives presented
what Iran is offering is a third
alternative an alternative that says
that you can live for yourself
rationally honesty with integrity
pursuing justice being proud committed
to your own morality and your own moral
perfection living the best life that you
can live for yourself in pursuit of your
own happiness that new mala code and
it's a new mall code at least since
the advert the advent of Christianity
it's it's it's somewhat reminiscent of
Aristotle's of Aristotle's moral code
again his focus on self on self on
egoism hey guys so what I read is asking
is to is to eliminate this the economy
that is being set up by the enemies of
the individual by the enemies of human
life by the enemies of freedom and
liberty it's not sacrifice for others or
be an sob no there is the third
alternative which is to be long-term
rationally self-interested long-term
rationally selfish long-term rationally
an egoist and if you understand what
egoism means what it means to live a
life what it means to flow is what it
means to attain human happiness then you
don't need the long term rational
anymore it's just to be an egoist to be
self-interested to be selfish it's time
to change the definition of the word
it's time to reject the 2000 years
definition of what morality was it's
time for a new mall code
a mall code based on what leads to
individual success what leads to
individual happiness not it's not about
money although money is a component of
happiness and success and flourishing
but it's not just about money it's about
living the best life that you can live
and making that your mall mission now
what is morality morality morality is
about the values the virtues and values
that you choose in pursuit of your life
the important values and the question is
who should be the beneficiary of those
values selfishness says you should be
that beneficiary you should benefit from
the stuff you produce and that nobody
has a right to guilt you into taking the
things that you could use they shouldn't
feel guilty about your success so many
businessman I me feel guilty why because
they've
thought that their self-interest is
somehow tainted that their willingness
their interest in pursuing success in
life put aside the money success in
producing great products in changing the
world based on their vision they are
taught that that is immoral somehow that
they should feel bad about it and their
inflicted with guilty or incredibly
successful people who've done wonderful
things in the world and they feel guilty
that's tragic and what why are they feel
guilty because they're told that the
motivation their motivation to make the
most of their life this selfish
motivation is somehow tainted and
somehow evil and that the ideal is some
mother Teresa some way No Mother Teresa
is not the moral ideal them all ideal is
a productive individual pursuing his
values without sacrificing to anybody
and without asking anybody to sacrifice
for him living an independent rational
successful happy life it's about each
individual that's what morality should
be about and that's what I knew and
offers us in her book the virtue of
selfishness thank you
[Applause]
Jean Epstein for five minutes
well it's time to change the dictionary
definition of the word I guess that's
what Yaron said also I guess part of the
joke is that I bet he said I bet that
Iran did find that definition in the
dictionary that did not include a moral
evaluation and I'll find it by God well
you know I actually went to the trouble
of looking up dictionaries published at
the time and they all obviously said
that that the word is indeed defined as
something that does include a moral
evaluation I rant just didn't bother to
do a homework do you know do you know if
I were to talk about it and said I could
I could criticize him for so many other
things sine rant perfect every time I
hear Yaran say iron Rand was a genius I
know what really is implicit in that
that she was some goddess some walk on
water person who could not make any kind
of mistake but well there's not a
thinker that I personally admire and
have learned from from Adam Smith to
Murray Rothbard to others who have not
delivered von mises who have not made
mistakes at times there's no reason to
live with those mistakes now yerin seems
to think that by pushing the word
selfishness by misusing the English
language even though there are so many
other words in the English language that
we could use to promote the individual
freedom that he has to keep using the
word selfishness and he seems to think
that he needs to say oh it's good to be
selfish that he can't tell businessmen
he can't quote Adam Smith who wrote in
this in The Wealth of Nations
I have never known much good done by
those who effected to trade for the
public good Adam Smith who said so
eloquently that that that all you have
to do is make a living provide a product
that people want to buy and you'll be
doing good in the world because
obviously people are taking the
affirmative step and wanting to buy it
that's all we need to be able to tell
the world
we don't have to confuse people with
foolish language we don't have to go
around saying greed is good but we have
to recognize again that greed is
channeled as Adam Smith said we don't
have to go around by the way where I
agree with yarn is we don't have to go
around saying that the world needs far
more benevolence then then then than it
ever has gotten because look dude did
you know that that 2% of nominal GDP
goes to charity in this country did you
know that as nominal chief GDP grows
that 2% continues and continues to grow
that's 400 billion dollars a year and
that's in a situation which government
does so much crowding out of charity so
we only have to point out that to this
small extent to which people in need
will need help that money is there the
compassion is there we only need to
point out that the pursuit of happiness
that that that self-actualization that
the realization of self is very
important because we believe that people
people are compassionate we believe that
that people are energetic and they had
visions we don't have to call Steve Jobs
selfish because he had a vision what
vision did he have he had a vision that
the world could be liberated by the
products that he wanted us to buy he had
a vision for us all that's the vision he
had that's an idealistic vision that's
not a selfish vision and there are other
vision minor visionaries we we were we
had back-to-back obituaries about Sam
bass of the strand bookstore who died
recently whose vision whose sole goal
was that was to mark was to sell us
second-hand books at a disco because he
loved books we we had a we had a vision
of the guy ran Lincoln Plaza cinemas who
wanted to sell us art films the world is
filled with with idealists who really
want to sell us visions so we haven't
more than adequate vocabulary but by the
way that yarn has contributed to in
order to deal
with our vision for freedom and free
markets and we we can call a halt we can
end the craziness we can end a situation
in which Iran actually tells us that
that the word selfishness has no moral
moral implication I finally want to end
on event Yaran you want to find a
dictionary in which Iran found this my
hundred to your ten I pay you a hundred
you send it out you send out that
dictionary and you cite it I looked up
all the dictionaries that is goddamn
crazy because he is so desperate
desperate to defend this goddess 500 -
your Chan Gary thank you very much so
now we'll proceed to vote those of you
who are remote and those of you are here
I'm going to talk for a few minutes
while everybody votes until the
tabulator of the votes who's also seated
in the front row tells me that she has
them tabulated this is the first time I
have been to the soho forum even though
my day job keeps me in debates like this
not usually as highbrow or as meaningful
as this I have done my best to be
neutral between two dear and longtime
friends even though I am sometimes
referred to notwithstanding my
pre-vatican to Roman Catholicism as the
iron Rand of Fox News so stossel used to
call me up and say Church every time you
say taxation is theft my people are
killing me I said why are your people
killing you because you don't want to
say that taxation is theft the first
time I tried a case I walked out into a
courtroom there are about this many
people in the courtroom when you start
out as a judge you start out with small
claims cases so the typical cases the
drycleaner runt my dress but he also
tried to pick up my sister lawyer said
to me judge we need a translator for
this case because my client doesn't
speak English I said what language that
your clients speak he said Italian I
called the courthouse administrator to
see if the Italian translator was
available and she was not so I said to
the throngs is there anybody here that
speaks Italian who the guy in the back
raised his hand
sup we swear him in to translate
literally here's exactly literally what
happened lawyer - translator give the
court your name translator to witness
what is it your name let me see where
this is gonna go or I can't I'll ask
your next question lawyer - translator
give the court your address translator -
witness where is it your house' I looked
at this character I said I thought you
told me that you could speak Italian he
said I can te Rana but my English she's
not at Oh God one time I was trying a
case involving a drug distribution even
though I'm of the view that you can put
into your body whatever you want I did
take an oath to uphold the laws of the
state of New Jersey which employed me as
a judge actually wasn't the state that
employed me was the Constitution the
state paid the salary and the state
police had stopped a a truck load of
cocaine coming off the George Washington
Bridge into Fort Lee 1,500 pounds of
cocaine I know nobody was gonna want to
be a juror in this case but I had this
many jurors potential jurors from whom I
had to choose 12 will had no bias no
interest no prejudice no interest in the
outcome no knowledge of the facts like a
brand-new naive judge I said is there
anybody here that doesn't want to be in
this jury leading the back raise their
hand yes madam what is it I can't be on
the jury because of my occupation I'm
thinking what the hell does she do for a
living all right madam what do you do
she said Your Honor I am a soothsayer a
soothsayer this is 1992 and you're
calling yourself a soothsayer I
foolishly said how does that keep you
from being on the jury she said judge I
already know how the trial ends up I
should have said tell us now lady and
save us the next three weeks in the
courtroom so when I was a freshman at
Princeton taking economics 101 and I was
home for Thanksgiving you're on and Gina
booth heard this the first time I was in
childhood bedroom having been away at
college since August and the first night
I fell asleep in my childhood bedroom
and my childhood bed in my parents home
as a freshman at Princeton I fell asleep
reading a book for economics 101 and the
next morning when my mother woke me up
she had the wooden spoon in her hands
what's this all about the book that was
on my chest was called the virtue of
selfishness she goes Princeton ruined
you how can you read a book like this
Josh that's gonna affect the voting I
think we have the results
mother it's about economics so she was
she was 42 then she's 92 today so
whenever she wants to needle me and
remind me of this event she goes
princeton rune to judge the judge should
have been a warm-up act
are we ready with the results note that
I had nothing to do with the tabulation
okay to start the at the start of the
debate the affirmative had 47% of the
vote and at the end of the debate 57% of
the vote for a 10% percentage point
change and the negative had 20% of the
vote to start 35 percent of the votes
and for a 15 percentage point change so
gene takes today and the bars open
[Applause]
Thank You everybody and then I know that
you're on doesn't want to hear this God
love you
[Laughter]